the White House insists a proposal to
send asylum seekers to so-called
sanctuary cities is not an attempt at
political revenge well president Trump
revived the idea on Friday after White
House officials said it had been killed
Democrats and other critics argue that
moving migrants to states counties and
cities that do not cooperate with
immigration officials would be cruel and
illegal Paula Reid is at the White House
Paula good morning some people say the
president's even doing this to distract
from the Mullah report I think there may
be some truth to that Nora right now the
White House insists this idea is still
on the table as the president ramps up
his attacks on asylum seekers and
doubles down on his signature campaign
promise to restrict illegal immigration
ahead of the 2020 campaign over the
weekend Sarah Huckabee Sanders said this
idea of moving to t knees to sanctuary
cities was brought up at the staff level
and dismissed because of logistical
concerns but after the president
appeared to embrace it last week they're
once again looking at how to make it
happen but using detainees for what even
the president suggests his political
retaliation would face immediate legal
challenges ones that would be hard for
the administration to surmount but to
get to your point Norah for president
Trump
this keeps immigration in the headlines
this enrages his rivals and galvanizes
his base all good reasons for President
Trump to want to keep this on the table
for the time being Gayle Paula there
seems to be a strategy there thank you
very much